viçosa é assim assim e só usam
em viçosa ii onde eu viçosa cidadezinha
do país das alagoas terra de tanta coisa
ruim mas terra de tanta coisa boa
me chama joão paulo falcão pai marido e
professor dos melhores alunos e alunas
que eu poderia ter a minha cidade é bela
minha cidade é linda é a minha cidade
trago comigo a bandeira mas tem uma
realidade que eu gostaria de falar pra
vocês eu gostaria que vocês agora
fechassem um pouco os olhos imaginassem
comigo seguinte
estamos entre estamos entrando em uma
escola pública não é qualquer escola é a
escola pública
estamos passando agora pelo portão
portão de ferro grande do lado direito
nós temos o vigilante com um cadeado em
uma das mãos
na outra mão algumas chaves e vai ele
vai dizendo em bora bora bora ou fechar
o portão bora bora bora bora e você
entra naquela naquela escola naquela
instituição de ensino
quando de repente empurrão e você fica
meio que apavorado mas você vai entrando
uns colegas tomaram banho outros não uns
colegas comeram outros não
uns colegas com os pais e outros não
uma voz lá no fundo grita aqueles que
moram na cidade e pelo lado direito os
que moram no sítio vai pro lado esquerdo
segregação
os fora de faixa por favor para turma é
f g e os que estão na idade vai pra
tomar abc
gostaria que vocês abrirem os olhos e
nós estamos agora entrando na sala de
aula o professor de matemática entre
outras coisas ele ele fala sobre a
matéria ele fala sobre a aula ele fala
sobre o conteúdo
mas entre outras coisas ele faz uma
menção aos filmes de terror
e ele põe a mão o dedo indicador na boca
e faz aquela voz horrível x silêncio que
quem manda sou eu
eu não sou pago para receber esse abuso
de vocês não estão na escola pública
quer coisa melhor pra outra
aqui o ensino sou eu que mando aqui sou
eu que falo somente eu que falo eu
gostaria que os meus alunos tivessem
observassem tivesse um dos melhores
tivesse o melhor das minhas aulas mas
que a hora é essa que eu estava dando
essas palavras eu falei em determinada
época
eu comparo as minhas aulas antigas com
as olimpíadas sendo que não são
olimpíadas convencionais são as
olimpíadas da apatia são as olimpíadas
do desânimo são as olimpíadas que forma
uma bolha uma bolha sobre os alunos e os
alunos eles não gostam dessas aulas
a primeira prova das olimpíadas que eu
falo para vocês é o remédio de peso o
atleta gira seu peso e lança esse peso
o professor ele joga o conteúdo na sala
pé quem quiser quem pegou aprendi que
não pegou não aprende e segue o barco
segundo segunda prova
o nado sincronizado é bem interessante
o nado sincronizado é quando você sai de
um conselho
assim a coordenadora fala tudo tem que
fazer assim assim-assim assim você faz
você é o dono da sala de aula
você sabe a realidade dos seus alunos
outras pessoas não o terceiro e bem
interessante
é uma visão de futuro que o professor
tem nas olimpíadas da apatia que é
justamente o tiro a distância tiro a
longa distância no primeiro dia de aula
os alunos loucos lá pensando o que fazer
o professor dizer para todo mal
comportado no final do ano eu vou
reprovar é o famoso terrorismo
no final do ano vou pegar quem está me
atrapalhando
isso ocorre demais as minhas aulas
estavam assim então treme na base o que
é que eu vou fazer
então procurei curadores eu procurei
pessoas gurus que me orientasse em de
alguma forma
o primeiro deles para francisco nova
francisco quando ele fala que você deve
construir pontes e não muros
você deve formar parcerias
o segundo deles bill gates quando ele
diz que o sucesso nos negócios é saber
aonde o mundo vai chegar lá primeiro o
terceiro
cortella quando ele diz que você tem que
fazer o melhor com aquilo que você tem
na condição que você tem enquanto você
não tem algo melhor pra fazer melhor
ainda
eu comparo os meus alunos
eu comparo a minha realidade os alunos
que estão entrando nas escolas nas
instituições de ensino e ocuparam a
lagartas
vou fazer uma breve análise gia a
metamorfose da borboleta
eu comparo alagadas eles entram nas
escolas vorazes comendo tudo que pega
tudo que bati nele já vai comendo assim
com a ascensão dos alunos
agregando conhecimento a todo momento se
enchendo de conhecimento e criatividade
chega ao ponto que eles se tornam
crisálidas é a hora que eles entram na
escola eles ficam imóveis parados
sobrevivendo daquilo que eles comeram
antes daquilo que daquilo daquele
conhecimento prévio que tinha antes
por favor gostaria de fazer uma pergunta
vocês quem gostaria que a crise aliada à
vista agora pouco se tornasse borboleta
levanta a mão por favor alguém gostaria
que a crise de se transformar 100
borboleta
obrigado eu também mas para isso tem um
processo em 2017
na minha escola na escola municipal
pedro carnaúba eu iniciei um projeto
chamado robótica açúcar acional e nós
conseguimos implantar uma coleta na
cidade onde essa coleta de materiais de
resíduos eletrônicos eu pegar esse
material leve ver
levo até a sala os alunos desmontam e
nós temos como foi lá em 2017
saíram os primeiros protótipos e
protótipos foram estes saíram garras
mecânicas saíram carrinhos com garrafas
pet
saíram carrinhos com caixinha de
adoçante e por aí vai
mas como é que eu vou conseguir fazer
com que estes própria esses protótipos
eles se tornem em eles se transformem em
conhecimento para os alunos
após sondagens com os meus alunos
eu entendi que eles estavam tendo muitas
dúvidas nas estratégias de cálculo de
multiplicação por exemplo que foi que eu
fiz
lancei pra eles a idéia de fazerem o
labirinto sustentável por exemplo no
labirinto sustentável para que vocês
coloquem os obstáculos para que os
alunos façam os obstáculos ele tem que
traçar linhas
e colunas na base do labirinto e assim
eles aprendem a multiplicação de linhas
e colunas os alunos eles tinham dúvida
também uma coisa chamada soma de 10 se
mais o que foi que eu pensei vou colocar
barata na na sala de aula e assim
aparecerão as baratas elétricas que são
lindas mas são feitas de escova de roupa
velha com o motorzinho que a gente
retira de impressora com o motorzinho
que a gente retira lá do joystick do
videogame
assim o funcionamento dessas baratas
elétricas é justamente o somatório das
pilhas é uma ligação insere 1,5 mais 1,5
mais 1,5
então assim eles aprenderam a somar
números decimais
na prática o primeiro na prática depois
na teoria
então a gente tava voando lá em 2017 foi
massa em 2018 arretado e daí a gente
começou a voar rumo mas como como quem
já está lá crescendo os alunos estão
motivados agora os alunos eles estão
gostando da aula os alunos eles estão
querendo assistir à aula mas as flechas
foram lançadas críticas foram feitas
críticas não construtivas mas
destrutivas e eu como um guerreiro um
guerreiro da educação eu sou professor
eu não poderia deixar nenhuma flecha
acertados nos alunos
e foi nessa dessa nessa hora
desculpa e foi nessa hora que eu tremi
na base quase desistir
olhei pro lado lembrou outro em um dos
dias
triste com raiva mesmo com a água
encontrei com um salão na rua alice
professor ou não se o professor de
robótica da escola
sou meu querido sou eu mesmo ele disse
como é que esse motor funciona então um
aluno me fez
voltar me fez dar um passo atrás na
idéia que eu queria desistir
então esse aluno chegou pra mim e assim
o faz funcionar o motorzinho que quebrou
ela vai de novo
ensinar robótica com material
sustentável para os alunos
e aí pessoal desse dia em diante o nosso
projeto já recolheu mais de 1.800 quilos
de resíduos eletrônicos
lá na minha cidade de viçosa nós temos
hoje mais de 750 alunos impactados
diretamente multiplicando essa ideia por
onde eles andam nós temos sete pontos de
coleta de material separado
estrategicamente na nossa cidade
as exposições as palestras as oficinas
elas são protagonizados pelos alunos
porque eles precisam ensinar aquilo que
eles aprenderam na prática na sala e pra
isso eles protagonizam mesmo
são eles que vão é eu tenho dois casos
aqui pra citar pra vocês
o primeiro caso de uma aluna chamada
maria aparecida ela foi nossa aluna lá
em 2017 e hoje ela está no instituto
federal campus viçosa
ela é uma das melhores alunas do curso
de tecnologia que tem lá nuno campos e
ela está voando ela está voando ela
rompeu a bolha ela está agora
conseguindo prêmios ela está agora
conseguindo fazer formular programar
principalmente os aplicativos outra ela
está voltando à escola para ensinar
programação para os colegas que ela
deixou o segundo exemplo é de uma aluna
chamada cloud running
ela se juntou com outro aluno luiz
marcos se juntou com outro aluno que foi
nathan estão fazendo aplicativos na
escola estadual escola estadual joaquim
diegues e daí qual aplicativo que eles
estão formando agora é um tira dúvidas
para o enem
eles notaram que os colegas estavam com
muita dúvida em português matemática e
daí eles fizeram um aplicativo estão
terminando a produção para que os
colegas baixe esse aplicativo
tire suas dúvidas de português e
matemática então imagina vocês pessoal
tocar um aluno com uma idéia é plantar
uma semente em um aluno lá no ensino
fundamental
lá no ensino fundamental e hoje este
aluno ele ser e hoje este aluno ele ser
destaque em suas instituições
instituição de ensino médio instituição
federal e na educação superior
eu gostaria que quando você escutar sem
a partir de hoje uma sirene uma buzina
uma chamada para entrar ou sair da sala
vocês soubessem vocês entendessem que
por trás daqueles muros daquela
instituição de ensino existe um
professor que está dando duro matando um
leão por dia para transformar a educação
que a educação se torne de qualidade que
seja uma escola pública de qualidade
então vocês agora me dê licença que eu
vou tentar impactar outras realidades
até a próxima aula
[Aplausos]